[Musique]
longtemps réservée à une élite le bio
s'impose chaque jour davantage dans
notre assiette producteurs et
restaurateurs re découvre peu à peu le
goût pour les produits 100 bio bio
dynamie circuits courts quels sont les
effets de ces nouvelles pratiques
agricoles dans les cuisines de nos chefs
[Musique]
eric roy et maraîchers spécialisée dans
les mini légumes et les chefs des plus
grandes tables se les arrachent carottes
navets panique ils sont beau tendre et
ça c'est qu'ils font l'objet d'une
attention extrême
nos produits sont calibrés triés
nettoyés par est par exemple voyez ces
petites feuilles on prend le soin d
enlever avant d expédier
de ce fait là le produit il peut être
consommé intégralement donc cru cuit
toutes les utilisations sont possibles
ça m'a fait évoluer moi aussi sur ma
façon de faire parce que j'ai proposé un
peu plus de feuillages qu'auparavant
parce que le cuisinier l'utiliser le
feuillage donc en fait c'est ainsi un
cercle vertueux parce que tout le monde
sait s'est hissée vers le haut cela fait
déjà longtemps qu eric roy élève ses
légumes sans pesticides ni engrais
chimiques
mais il vient lui aussi de s'engager sur
le chemin de la conversion vers le
précieux label bio une façon
d'officialiser sa recherche de
l'excellence
voilà comment rendre à un cuisinier
heureux à quelques centaines de mètres
toujours sur les terres limoneuses de
saint genou entre chair et loire les
maraîchers bio de l'île y exploite deux
hectares de légumes de plus grosse
taille est totalement biologique
aujourd'hui silva le maraîcher reçoit la
visite de vincent le chef cuisinier du
restaurant tous bonjour le qg en ce
moment c'est quoi les shows taqwa
bruxelles bruxelles chou blanc rouge
l'un des shows frisés
entre les deux hommes le contact est
régulier le travail de l'un se nourrit
du travail de l'autre se trouvait un
morceaux d'agneau braisé avec ça un pot
de miel et des poires d'auteur et du
persil est juste à côté un plat ici le
goûter avec ses avoirs
c'est un péché c'est négatif de tout ce
qu'il fait et surtout de sa démarche et
partir du produit brut à chaque fois
dans tous les plats qu'il fait ça c'est
quand même assez rare pour être souligné
l'idée du restaurant imac cuisine c'est
que c'est les fournisseurs qu'ils font
et qui qui me donne les ingrédients pour
faire mes plats avions pas l inverse
tu veux essayer de cuisiner le tout les
tiges bon vincent téléphone on retrouve
vincent dans la cuisine de son
restaurant
premier geste du matin la tournée des
fournisseurs à l'eau thierry savez ça va
est-ce que ça pêche non bon d'accord
j'avais désespoir de faire du du mulet
ou du silure je me rappelle quand tu
quand tu as des petites pièces dossier
leur particularité de ce fonctionnement
vincent établi son menu du jour en
fonction de ce qui est disponible chez
ses fournisseurs et non sur commande
on doit constamment jongler un petit peu
et c'est ça qui est à la fois
contraignant est à la fois un challenge
constant j'ai quelqu'un en face avec qui
je peux discuter et qui et c'est vrai
que ça guide sa guide la façon dont on
travaille le produit et ça
personnellement ça me pousse à le
respecter un peu plus
[Musique]
l'évolution par rapport à avancer qu'on
considérait qu'il y avait un très bon
produit dans les prés dans les
établissements étoilés et gastronomie
uniquement et je pense qu'aujourd'hui ça
la palette est beaucoup plus large en
fait et ça c'est bien
et ici on se plaît dans le rôle de
passeur une assiette et qui a des
rutabagas des épinards et des chants
bruxelles c'est intéressant de le dire
sont des rigoles frais qui ont été
ramassés par notre maraîcher bio le
matin avec vincent appuyer vos raisons
par exemple amener un morceau de des
shin qui paraît presque un peu rose et
si on arrive à placer notre fournisseur
de cochon éleveurs de cochons en liberté
sur château renault on met aussi en
avant on a envie de transmettre des
choses
[Musique]
café restaurant le court-circuit à tour
aujourd'hui c'est jour de livraison une
fois par mois on les livre en général
tout ce qui est à aiguilles farine
céréales et charcuterie tout bio et tout
local les produits apportés par l'ati
biaudet rentre pleinement dans la
philosophie du lieu
car ici on se veut locavore et on est
fier d'afficher en bonne place la liste
détaillée des fournisseurs
[Musique]
ouvert il y a deux ans et demi le court
circuit n'est pas seulement un
restaurant c'est aussi un lieu
d'expérimentation sociale
quand on vient on est aux courts
circuits
on n'est pas juste de simples salariés
fin là je suis pas en train de faire la
cuisine juste simplement cuisiner suis
aussi en train d'utiliser des produits
je sais d'où qu'ils viennent nous c'est
qu'il est produit
je connais ces personnes ne connaissent
aussi et
et donc il ya vrai une vraie démarche
globale en fait le fait de consommer
local d'avoir que des produits locaux
était une contrainte mais tu es plutôt
une vraie n'aurait zone de liberté parce
qu'en fait on a une déclinaison
déclinaison de recettes
enfin je sais pas on prend l'alantique
par exemple lentilles on la décline en
salade en tartinades on a fait des
tartes
on a mis ça dans des crumbles par
exemple le fait d'avoir finalement des
produits forme d'accord une diversité
très large mais pas tous accessibles et
bien ça à force à la créativité
les clients comptent eux aussi une place
particulière il se sert des barras
échange et c'est justement ce qu'ils
apprécient contact est facile avec les
gens peuvent se discuter avec eux de
leur fille leur façon de travailler de
leurs protecteurs parce qu'ils les
connaissent vraiment personnellement à
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya vraiment une
dimension humaine en plus de la
restauration le lieu s'est rapidement
enraciné dans la vie du quartier
il s'est constitué un véritable réseau
avec les autres acteurs du bio local
[Musique]
quand deux passionnés se rencontrent en
bon voisin sébastien le chef cuisinier
de la cantine scolaire de bléré et
stéphane l'éleveur pourrait passer des
heures ensemble c'est l'heure de manger
way but à l'heure du casse-croûte et on
et pia sont elles sont pas sauvages mais
toujours admiratif de son travail et des
animaux quand on voit que les animaux
sont heureux ça rappelle l'odeur de la
campagne râlant mais des animaux sont
bons on sait quand on a pour du
qualitatif il ya quoi de produits
chimiques à rien c'est ainsi que du
naturel
la ferme des turbos dispose de son
propre laboratoire de transformation et
les saucisses qui sont fabriqués
aujourd'hui c'est une recette créée en
commun quand c'est presque qui va le
manger en fait ce soit les collectivités
sans pouvoir mieux en fait
ça nous retrouvons sébastien et ses
saucisses dans la cuisine de son collège
à bléré avec son équipe il prépare
chaque jour plus de 600 repas le défi
servir aux élèves une nourriture
toujours plus saine et locale
[Musique]
on a de l'épeautre au bio de touraine
avec topinambours et des petites
betteraves qui file de fromages sur ce
soit joli
on a aussi des lentilles pour la bio de
touraine une salade de pissenlits noah
lardons avec un titeuf voilà mots les
faits sur place
donc voilà des produits qui sont jolis
au visuel et puis descente un petit peu
des carottes râpées des thomas croit pas
ou peu de produits emballés tout est
cuisiné maison avec un soin tout
particulier accordé à la présentation
le tout en respectant les coûts d'une
comptine classique et on est là pour les
enfants c'est eux qui vont transformer
demain pense qu'on a une démarche de
demain des bons produits aux enfants
pour le plus tard vous avez tous les
partis mais dont la flotte de sea dur
vous avez le résultat est exemplaire 95
% des élèves scolarisés reste au
déjeuner
il ne leur dites sur tout pas qu'ils
mangent à la cantine
il préfère nettement dire qu'ils vont au
restaurant scolaire
[Musique]
elsa est ingénieur agronome de formation
reconverti dans le métier de traiteur
elle a gardé de sa vie d'avant son goût
immodéré pour les plantes sauvages des
plantes qu'elle cueille elle-même dans
la nature
ça me permet d'alimenter mais
préparation avec des plantes sauvages
qui ont des saveurs hameau aromatiques
en fait prononcer qui agrémentent les
plats et donc ça se cuisine en entrée
comme en plats commandés sert donc là
par exemple vous avez des graines de
bears
c'est les dernières à mon avis parce
qu'on est en fin de saison et avec les
fruits et je vais pouvoir préparer un
gâteau des cookies que je vais incorporé
dans la dans la pâte
[Musique]
elsa est un traiteur un peu atypique
elle recherche un vent qu'ils n'offrent
mais toujours avec la même exigence pour
la qualité des matières premières le
lien aux plantes me permets d'énormément
créé il ya encore beaucoup de choses à à
trouver et à innover en cuisine
végétarienne et les plantes sauvages est
beaucoup parce qu'elles sont riches en
protéines parce que elle apporte
certaines choses la démarche 100% ferait
pas peu de traiteur long bon ça a ses
inconvénients aussi je passe un temps
fou commandes à aller chercher
mes produits je conçois pas de
travailler autrement en fait c'est un
projet territorial et voilà je veux
travailler que les gens de ce territoire
je veux travailler avec les produits qui
qui pousse donc les plantes sauvages et
aussi des plantes cultivées qui sont de
très bonne qualité
lorsqu'elles viennent de maraîchers bio
qui sont de plus en plus nombreux à
antoine derrière des producteurs bio et
des lieux d'approvisionnement toujours
plus nombreux des consommateurs de plus
en plus exigeants mais pas toujours
facile de dégoter les bonnes adresses
pour manger bio et local en touraine le
guide à table on fait le recensement
chaque année 7 s'est donné l'obligation
de montrer là on pouvait consommer du
bio local donc acheté en marche et en
magasins directement à la ferme mais
aussi consommés dans les restaurants
voilà la production d'abord bio et
locale a augmenté de manière assez
considérable on est passé à peu près 2
par rapport à notre guide 271 adresse à
300 adresses pratiquement ce qui est
important aussi avoir c'est que la
consommation en termes de restauration
est aussi
en évolution on a vu ces cinq dernières
années fleurir beaucoup de petits
restaurants et de restaurants et
gastronomique même utilisant les
produits bio locaux et donc ça ces
nouveautés aussi c'est que maintenant on
a un panel de 2,2 petit restaurant de
même au quotidien tous les jours
si on veut se restaurer manière simple
et pas trop cher on peut arriver à
trouver assez facilement sa maman
on est encore très loin d'une
généralisation de ces pratiques
vertueuses
[Musique]
mais l'idée fait petit à petit son
chemin et si le tout bio et le tout
local ne fait pas encore figure de
standards le consommateur lui se sent de
plus en plus libre de faire ce choix